[Music]
thank you
whoops
hello and welcome once again to what is
one of our favorite programs here at
some TV and that is I'd like to know
it's our favorite because we get to
answer your Bible questions we get to
find out what is on your mind and in
your heart and it allows us to do what
we like to do and let's dig into the
word of God for the truths that are
hidden there my name is c a Murray and
I'm in the company of two distinguished
gentlemen uh our founder and speaker and
president Pastor Stephen pastor always
good to have you here
the feeling is absolutely mutual oh
praise the Lord and and our our newest
addition someone that we have are
learning to love and to appreciate very
much Pastor David Salazar Pastor again
good to have you here thank you for
having me here it's a blessing to be
here with you and join the team praise
the Lord uh Pastor Salazar is kind of
new why don't you tell us a little bit
about him Pastor sure I'll be glad to
um I just got back from Ecuador as you
guys know
at an Evangelistic series there very
successful praise the Lord and uh David
is from Ecuador that's right the middle
of the Earth
of course we were well acquainted with
uh Pastor Salazar he was working in
Florida and
um he came here for a couple of Simcoe
symposiums and uh we're very glad that
he decided to join our team at Secrets
unsealed full time and so we look
forward to great things one of the
positive points is that he's able to
work in English and Spanish right and
then over above that he has a very solid
theological mind good solid belief in
the evidence message and so Pastor
Salazar we are glad that you're here we
look forward to working together and
producing programming that will impact
the world thank you I'm very thankful to
be here the Lord has led me this way so
I'm I know that this is where he wants
me to be amen you praise the Lord you
know Pastor sometimes you meet people
and you kind of like them right off you
know uh uh he's that way uh we met a few
a few days ago when I I got back from
Panama and uh right away I had met him
before at another Ministry but I didn't
know him uh and so we kind of got
acquainted uh kind of like him you know
like like his style uh like his Theology
and uh so he's a he's a good fit yeah I
don't kind of like him I really like it
we'll praise the Lord
when the boss likes you are in good
state so it's quite all right thank you
like you both already too praise the
Lord Pastor why don't you open up uh
with us in prayer uh then I got one or
two things to go to say and then we'll
we'll we'll pass it to pass the board
let's pray heavenly father thank you
once again Lord for allowing us to come
together and to share from your word the
answers to the questions a lot of our
viewers have we thank you for giving us
the the opportunity and the blessing to
expose your word and to let the word of
God your word speak to them and clearly
answer the questions please we ask that
your Holy Spirit may lead us and that it
once again you may be the one that
teaches the truth between Jesus name
amen amen we've been talking about
questions questions perhaps you have a
question that you would like us to
answer to wrestle with a little bit you
can send your questions to TV at some
tv.org that is TV at
s-u-m-tv.org and we will get to them
just as soon as we possibly can as we
say weekly our list is rather impressive
it's getting longer by the day so if you
don't hear your question right away stay
with us stay by we will get to it we
promise and we also make you this
promise that we will give you the answer
if indeed an answer can be found from
the word of God we don't want to give
you man's opinion or my opinion or
pastor's opinion or pastor's opinion we
want to give you what the word of God
has to say we want to give you the word
of the Lord and so we promise to do that
from the word of God if an answer can be
found by the grace of God we will find
it and bring it to you so patience is a
virtue we'll get to them and we make you
that promise pass men
yes
yes uh the question that we have is very
interesting
it comes from Africa
and this is what the way it reads thanks
for your service for Jesus
I have a problem
I am working in a company in Africa
where nearly all and every worker is you
uh use the opportunity to steal money
from the highest of them to the lowest
which makes it hard for me to work in
such an environment
it made me more more confused when I see
those who practice these Evils are
accepted in many of our churches SDA
especially when they are giving
their large amount of money which they
got through uh through theft from
different government projects my concern
is that how do I get myself out from
these situations
um
so basically this is uh a question about
stealing from the government to get to
give to his church yes yes so the big
question is what do we have to say about
that well I I've Had The Purge of
ministering in Africa on several
occasions there is in some places a
culture of of theft particularly when it
is done uh against the government it's
not thought of as theft uh it's thought
of almost as liberating funds to do to
someplace else so there is in some
cultures and and we don't want to
castigate a whole continent but there
are in some places this idea that
stealing from the government is not
stealing uh and so and if you steal from
the government and give to the church
it's even better you sort of you sort of
sanitize the theft you know kind of
thing now the Bible doesn't still say
steal ye from Caesar and tip to God
very very true
um
the first thing one has to do is make
sure that you are part of the solution
and not the problem
you can't always control what others do
but you can always control what you do
you don't have to be part of that
um so the first thing you want to do is
make sure that your hands are clean that
you are right with God and that you are
not touching the unclean thing or part
of an unclean thought or AK ball you're
trying to do the best you can uh with
what is entrusted to you and to be
honest uh with that you shall not steal
now as to the situation I'll leave that
to you where these two well I have maybe
just a thought about this you know it's
is what the Bible says in first Timothy
6 10 the For the Love of Money is the
root of all evil which while some
coveted after they have heard from the
faith and Pierce themselves through with
many Sorrows so in some ways we can see
that those Adventists who are stealing
from the government
it's really uh because I love money and
we understand that that is as Paul
mentions the root of all evil and not
only that the end result unless they
repent from that will be
Eternal termination I mean they're going
to be lost because it will not be they
cannot keep the faith the pure faith
knowing or holding to this sin of
stealing even though it may seem that is
okay to be bribed or to you know have uh
money that is easily accessible or
because everybody else does it may seem
okay to them is not really what I think
they should be known for we should be
because of truth of honesty of
transparency and uh you know I think the
admonition here that Paul is telling us
and and we need to remember is that if
we uh perhaps don't share with them that
that love of money is going to cause
them to air from the faith
um you know they need to really remember
maybe this friend from Kenya from is it
Kenya or from Africa we don't know
exactly where he's from but wherever
he's from you know maybe to share these
principles of the Bible and with them
and and warn them that unless they
repent they're going to be airing from
the faith
you know some people live by the
the wrong principle that we're supposed
to be like Robin Hood it's okay to steal
from the rich as long as you give it to
the poor but I want to read this
statement uh where Ellen White is
commenting on the Commandment that says
Thou shalt not steal
uh this is from Patriarchs and Prophets
page 309 pretty embracing this is the
eighth commandment she wrote both public
and private sins are included in this
prohibition amen the eighth commandment
condemns uh man stealing and slave
dealing
and forbids Wars of Conquest it condemns
theft and robbery
it demands strict integrity and the
minutest details of the Affairs of life
it forbids overreaching in trade and
requires the payment of just debts or
wages
it declares that every attempt to
Advantage oneself by the ignorance
weakness or Misfortune Of Another is
registered as fraud in the books of
Heaven that's pretty embracing pretty
embracing all dishonesty in other words
uh you know it reminds me of the story
of Aiken
where you know he stole things from
Jericho God had reserved these things
for the service of the sanctuary yes it
was the first city that they came to in
Canaan that they conquered which was
really the tithe of the land everything
was to be given to God's cause in this
individual Aiken you know he took
several things for himself by the way I
think that this commandment would also
involve
um not taking not not returning the ties
yes you know be included in this because
I would be stealing from God
so anyway I think that uh the answer to
this question in fact I know the answer
to this question is that it is always
wrong to steal in all circumstances yes
yes definitely Ellen White says in the
art desire it remember this quote from
way back in college no deviation from
strict Integrity will meet God's
approval uh so that's in all your
business dealings not uh you know giving
less than is expected going to work and
uh punching in late and coming in early
or punching in early and coming you know
that kind of thing
um putting your finger on the scale when
you're measuring out things you know no
deviation from strict Integrity meet
God's approval Exodus 23 verse 2 uh Thou
shalt not follow a multitude to do evil
even though everyone around you is doing
it that does not
uh sanitize it uh you you you cannot be
a part of that sometimes it's it's you
know you have a job uh you just have to
be the Daniel there you know you have to
you've got to sort of and sometimes
doing right will cause you to get into
trouble with those who are doing wrong
so that is to be expected uh yet uh you
have to do right of course your ultimate
uh thing you can you can quit but you
can always just give up a job yeah you
know you can't just walk away but you
have to stand for Christ uh even though
those around you are doing evil you know
and another important thing is take for
example Daniels that you mentioned
um he worked undoubtedly in this type of
environment that we find in this
question yeah and I'm not sure that he
lectured everyone there
but they could see a difference
in the way that he managed things yes
you know maybe we can just read a verse
that we find in Daniel chapter six
after he's delivered from the Lions then
um Daniel speaks to the king
and um let's see this uh would be in
verse let's begin at verse 20.
and when he came to the den this is the
king he cried out with a lamenting voice
to Daniel the king spoke saying to
Daniel Daniel servant of the Living God
has your God whom you serve continually
it's interesting the opinion that the
king had of Daniel been able to deliver
you from the Lions then Daniel said to
the king O King live forever my God sent
his Angel and shut the Lion's mouths so
that they have not hurt me and now comes
the reason because I was found innocent
before him yes and also O King I have
done no wrong before you
and so very clearly Daniel was honest in
all of his dealings not only with God
but also with the King and with everyone
that he worked with
and sometimes as we said uh with Joseph
sometimes turning your back on evil can
get you into hot water it can but the
same God that uh is with you will be
with you in the hot water particularly
if you're standing up for righteousness
absolutely and deliver you and the Lord
wants his people to shine you know
Daniel as you mentioned Pastor board uh
he's an example of that type of person
that had no fault they couldn't find
anything wrong in his behavior there's
nothing he could they could you know
even they though they dig I'm sure they
tried to look for anything that could uh
you know look at his character as as you
know just immoral perhaps he stole
something no they couldn't find anything
the only thing they could find him
guilty of is being loyal to the Lord
right so that shows you where we will
ultimately be tested upon you know and
you'd rather be faithful to the Lord
than to you know even if your boss is an
Adventist and is telling you to do this
or to You Know cover his you know this
deception you need to be strong and say
Lord I'm not gonna go against your word
I'm gonna take stick to what the truth
is and what the Bible wants me to do so
amen
praise the Lord hope we answer that
thoroughly I think that was a good
answer sometimes we we find ourselves in
situations that are going to test our
faith test our medal in the Lord uh
they're not going to be easy but when
you stand for the Lord you have the
privilege of knowing that the Lord is
standing with you amen and um so we
commend that to you and hopefully that
is of help to you
um
our next question from John comes from
the Bahamas and uh he's from Long Island
in the Bahamas I've been to the Bahamas
uh uh my sister-in-law uh taught there
for many many years my wife's sister uh
was Christ manifesting himself in an
Angelic form while he was commander of
the Angels is this why Satan thought he
could be equal with Christ does the
spirit of Prophecy mention this I am
sure that I had heard something uh some
time ago but I cannot pinpoint uh the
source where or where it actually is
all right uh let me start answering this
question with what do you find in
Revelation 12 you know verse 7. it's a
very
a well-known verse from The Book of
Revelation and there it says the
following says and there was war in
heaven Michael and his angels fought
against the dragon and the dragon
thought and his angels so we know that
Christ is the one he's speaking of and
this is Michael his name before coming
to Earth as our savior in the Bible is
he's called Michael and Michael uh is
also called the Archangel in the Bible
as well so the the idea that Christ had
um
another name that or another I won't say
Angelic form but he was the commander of
the Angelic hosts and he was there as
Michael whose name means one like God in
other words his Essence he is of course
God he was a creator of all things so in
that sense he was the linked to to the
Angels by being the Archangel the one
that was like God and with that name
Michael that is the connection there but
uh I wouldn't necessarily see that he
was
seen by the angels as one that was
created or nothing like that they knew
that he was God now Satan Lucifer it is
true that he in Isaiah and in Ezekiel
28 speaks of how he fell from heaven and
then it mentions there that he wanted to
be like God in other words he wanted to
be like Michael he wanted to be in that
same element and or the same position as
Jesus was uh but uh these probably were
where I think that we have to be careful
not to make him think that Christ was an
angel he was not a you know an angel
like like the other Angels were created
he is God and his only name there is
Michael so that probably
but what else do you guys have to say
about these then you have much more to
mention I had a teacher in the Seminary
who had a great impact on me
I think he had three phds
he was a leader of a self-supporting
institution in France very humble drove
around campus and a beat up Volkswagen
Beetle
but the extremely intellectual his name
is Carson Johnson we have several of his
books that we carry here a tremendous
philosopher and he provided some
significant information
that Christ before he came to this world
had assumed the position of an Angel the
commander of the Angel hosts and that's
what led Lucifer to be jealous of him
Lucifer was not jealous of the father
right because the father is the absolute
King of the universe but he was jealous
of Jesus now who do we find our Rivals
who are our Rivals you know I would not
consider that um David that what's his
name
um the owner of Amazon Bezos
I would not consider him to be a rival
in business because we're very different
in terms of our position of equality
right of course we find our Rivals among
those who are on the same level as us
and so Lucifer you know Ellen White
tells us that uh you know God consulted
Jesus in the creation of the world and
we're also told in Patriarchs and
Prophets that the father placed Jesus to
be the commander of the Angel hosts
right and uh so Lucifer was filled with
jealousy you know why why does he get
special privileges that I don't get that
was the original reason no we can't say
reason but that's the uh the issue that
led to the controversy uh and so he
believed that Jesus had assumed the
position of an Angel and you know just
just here in Daniel chapter 3 we find
something very interesting that seems to
indicate that it's the story of the
Three young men that were thrown into
the lion's den
you know when Nebuchadnezzar sees the
fourth individual in the furnace uh it's
interesting how he identifies him this
is in verse 25 of Daniel 3. look he
answered this is the king I see four men
loose walking in the midst of the fire
and they are not hurt in the form of the
fourth is like the Son of God
but then later on in the chapter in
verse 28
now the same nebuchadnezzer
says Nebuchadnezzar spoke saying blessed
be the god of Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego who sent his Angel and
delivered his servants who trusted in
him yeah so who was the son of God in
the furnace in in Nebuchadnezzar's
estimation it was it was the son of God
and of course we know from Daniel 12
verse 1 that you mentioned that uh
Michael right is the one that is being
referred to Michael the Archangel and no
suppressor you're right and this uh
there's a another places in the Bible
where Michael or Jesus is called the
angel of the Lord so he did take that
position as you mentioned very clearly
as the commander as an angel as the
Archangel
um never really giving of course his his
his position as a Son of God or as equal
with God but he lowered himself in need
you can use that expression to be as as
equal as possible with the angels so
yeah and that's why Michael you know
it's his name before he came
to you know as he came as a man to to
for to the world and his and his name
the name Michael means who is like God
right uh you know this reminds me being
that we're talking about different names
that are given in the Old Testament he's
also called the commander of the of the
hosts of the Lord uh in Joshua chapter
five oh my goodness uh I was waiting for
you to stop talking about
I've got it right here
I'll give you the privilege
no I'm at verse 13. I think that's what
we would probably begin
um and the point is I guess I should
read it very quickly and it came to pass
let me look at my time and it came to
pass when Joshua was about Jericho who
lift up his eyes and looked and behold a
man stir opposite of him and Joshua went
to him and said to him are you for us or
for our adversaries so he said but as
commander of the armor of the Lord I am
now come Joshua fell on his face to the
Earth and worshiped and said to him what
does my Lord say to a servant
then the commander of the Lord's host
said to Joshua take off your sandal for
uh off your foot for the place where you
stand is Holy even though
um the the term Angelus is used whenever
Christ steps in it's it's known that
you're dealing with God uh one Angels
don't accept worship
uh we found that from Revelation 22. so
um he knew that he was dealing with with
God and and Christ always when he steps
in is is revealed as as God
um not as an angel per se but as as God
and it is recognized here in Joshua now
maybe you have another take on on that
or something to add Pastor the only
other place
where that identical expression
commander of the Lord's hosts is found
uh is in Daniel chapter eight where the
little horn is attempting to usurp yes
the place of the commander of the host
yes uh it says in Daniel chapter 8 verse
11 he even exalted himself
as high as the prince of the host it's
not translated the same way but is the
commander of hosts and uh and so what
Satan attempted to do in heaven he does
in Daniel 8 through the little horn
which means that the little horn is the
Antichrist in the sense that is the the
Emissary of the enemy of Christ who
coveted the position of Jesus in heaven
um excellent excellent so he's also
called the angel of his presence
and yeah uh so so he you know Jesus is
referred to with many names in the Old
Testament Michael the commander of the
host the angel is presence the I am
that's another name in in Exodus chapter
3 and we know that was Jesus because in
John 8 verse 58 Jesus said before
Abraham was I am and those who are
present picked up stones to throw at
Jesus that's right yeah so they knew who
he was claiming to be
um I think it's an interesting question
uh talking about manifesting himself but
whenever Christ
um can I use the term showed up they
knew they were dealing with God uh and
not an angel per se and of course to be
the commander of the Angel does not
Angels does not mean you have to be an
angel per se but that you are a
commander of the Angels you are the
leader of the Angels uh Christ is still
is still god well you know Jesus assumed
a human position on Earth he didn't
cease to be God right and so when he
assumed the position of commander of the
Angels he did not cease to be God
precisely so so in other words uh you
know his The Descent of Jesus did not
begin when he came to this earth in
heaven he had already subjected himself
to the authority of his father his
father named him and said you're going
to be the commander of the host and he
accepted the commission that's right so
so subjection to God's Authority is not
inferiority that's the point you know
some people say well if I if I have to
take orders then I'm inferior no no no
that's that's the way human beings think
that's not the Divine way of thinking
that's actually the Satan's way of
thinking you know he was not willing to
be content with the position that the
Lord had given him even though it was
the most exalted position of a creative
being yet he was that was not enough for
him he wanted something more and we have
to be very careful to uh not following
the same path you know we don't want to
either
surrender serve the Lord and realize
that if he places in a position to be
under someone or in a position of
servants or whatever it might be we
might not you know feel that we have to
not be happy with that position and just
want to you know take over and not be
willing to submit ourselves to to
whoever that or it might be so yeah his
uh his great sin was upward Mobility
he could not be God God is Creator he
was created correct there's simply no
way to cross that barrier amen he was
created so he could not go into the
councils of of creation because he had
nobility no ability to to create good
question and we thank you John for it
from the Bahamas we praise the Lord for
that amen well as we look at the clock
on the wall our time has fast slipped
into eternity we allow you to encourage
you to keep on studying the word of God
keep on reading send in your questions
we'll be glad to answer them until we
see you again God bless you be well be
safe
thank you
[Music]
foreign